a study found that more than 99% of
fraud voter fraud identified by a
Republican backed program is false they
are false positives there was a very
good study done by Harvard Yale and
Microsoft researchers who looked at this
system it's called interstate voter
registration cross-check program a lot
of you know it just as cross-check and
the criticism has been been that really
vague criteria is used to
disproportionately target people of
color for voter D registration and the
study figured out that if you vote in
Indiana the study looked at Indiana if
you if you vote in Indiana and share a
name and a birthdate with someone else
you might be D registered under the
false pretense of preventing double
voting even though you have many people
in the United States that share names
and birthdates who are not actually
double registered they're just different
people so Indiana has had the
cross-check system for years why is it
now a problem because previously when
the system identified a possible
duplicate registration the voter in
Indiana had the opportunity to confirm
their address to a voting official or
not vote for two election cycles before
they were automatically removed under
the new law with the exact same system
officials can now just remove the person
from the voter rolls immediately which
is a major major problem so the next
question is why are minority voters more
likely to be impacted it's a very simple
answer black Hispanic and Asian voters
are statistically more likely than white
voters to share a name and birthday with
others in the country Lee for example is
a really common Korean name 50% of US
racial minorities share last names
compared to just 30% of white Americans
so you can immediately see how applying
this same automatic system would
disproportionately deregister non-white
voters who of course disproportionately
are Democrats not Republicans and
right-wingers think the answer is well
these people should pick different names
you're telling me now you need to pick
correctly in order to not be
disenfranchised from voting not exactly
what the founding fathers had in mind
right the ratio between the legitimate
duplicate registrations and incorrect
flagging is one to two hundred okay to
put it a different way for every 200
incorrectly flagged duplicate voters by
this system the system finds one actual
duplicate registration and remember
being registered in two places is not a
crime as long as you're not voting twice
it is fine
to be registered in two places Trump's
daughter Tiffany Trump me I was
registered to vote in two places for a
while I still might be this is not a
crime you are not allowed to vote twice
but the duplicate registrations are not
actually the problem what's the right
number and by what I mean by what I mean
by that is if you correctly identify ten
duplicate registrations instead of one
for every 200 false positives would that
make sense with the system makes sense
then how skewed does this have to be for
us to all agree that it's a system that
should be removed and that's kind of the
crux of the issue not everybody agrees
that the incorrect flagging and removal
from the voter rolls of
disproportionately non-white voters is a
problem we know that Republicans want to
use voter suppression of minorities to
hurt Democrats right Mike ters aye
there's the video of Mike Terzi saying
exactly this voter ID which is going to
I don't remember what the quote was
deliver the state of Pennsylvania to
Mitt Romney in 2008 or so to 2012
whenever it was something like that
Republicans know this right if you point
this out to Republicans they see this as
a feature not a bug to use software
testing terms right a viewer wrote to me
and said David don't misunderstand this
the system isn't 99 percent inaccurate
its 99 percent accurate you're just not
just not a or admitting who the target
is which is a really really good point
they've been honest with us the
Republicans have been honest sometimes
behind closed doors typically in fact
about the whole point of voter ID and it
is to help
publicans win elections and that is
exactly what we are seeing the Indiana
cross-check system do the systems got to
go it's a disaster and it's not just
Indiana that has it